it's a millionaire theme our this is the
Dave Ramsey show we are doing away with
the mythology some of you with your
political crap have believed and some of
you with your sociology or your
socialist and communist college
professors taught you that millionaires
are all evil people that have done
something wrong and they all inherited
their money so they should be punished
and the money should be taken away from
them and we should redistribute the
wealth that's the crap that's going
around our culture so I'm introducing
you to real millionaires not mythology
and finding out how they really did it
if you're a millionaire call in will
tell your story we want to hear your
story the phone number is triple eight
eight two five five two two five Glenn
and Lou are with us in Kentucky hi guys
how are you
great how are you I am better than I
deserve thank you for being part of the
millionaire theme hour what is your net
worth our net worth is 1.5 million -
what's that unlisted it might be on the
call while we qualify we're surprised
we're here Dave why is that because it's
early in our life we started out
everything was was wrong if you looked
in the dictionary under stupid our
picture was there we we had a mortgage
that was 14 and a half percent interest
with an arm and a balloon payment half
the paycheck was going to that mortgage
payment we had purchased two new
vehicles one of which was borrowed
against a whole life insurance policy
hello and we borrowed against the my
401k to landscape the yard how stupid is
that how many years ago was all of that
oh that was a while back in back in the
early eighties
okay so 2530 years ago and actually 30
plus years ago so how old are you guys
now I'm 63 okay I'm sorry I'm you're 60
okay so this is like you guys were this
is the 30-year old version of you that
was that stupid yes absolutely cool now
what is your 1.5 million invested in 1.1
of it is in cash retirement funds mutual
funds mainly four hundred thousand as
our house okay cool
that's and your debt free yes we are
very good very good at them for a good
thing so what is your range of income
since your stupid 30 days - no I started
my first year out of college I my salary
was $14,000 mm-hmm
we are in the $200,000 range now with
fallenness everything with a salary of
about 150 thousand got you what do you
guys do for a living I'm retail
executive and Lou is a housewife okay
cool good and how much of this 1.5
million did you all inherit none usually
run of it at all okay and what are your
degrees in I graduated in business
management
mm-hmm and I was history major I'm sorry
stream nature you were a teenager
history made history major I'm sorry
your phone's breaking up okay okay all
right cool and your your GPA of what was
lose GPA she was about a 3.2 and I was a
3.3 okay cool and how much of this
wealth that you have acquired in the
last 30 years occurred because you
borrowed money to create wealth oh they
would have been a lot better if we had
in the bar we put we didn't borrow it to
get rid we borrowed and had to pay it
off it was it was one of the stupid
things got you got you and what part has
giving played in your financial plan
through these years we have given tithes
and offerings 15 percent throughout our
our married life we believe in it
substantially now that we're deep in the
baby step 7 we try to look for those who
are in need waitresses barbers and are
really working hard and we try and give
them substantial tips where we can we
people who are down in life and whatever
but the main thing for us is for the
past two decades we've been wanting to
serve a mission for our church and we're
now in a position to be able to do that
and we're gonna this fall leave and
serve for 18 months Wow mission very
cool very cool
love it what's the most expensive pair
of jeans you ever bought $40.00 okay
cool
and how many brand new cars did you buy
prior to having a million dollars after
the stupid 30 so let's put the stupid
30s behind us not after that and okay
bye good used cars but we can't and then
just drive it so what wheels are off
that that's much more we didn't start
getting ahead until we started doing
that but we bought the two cars when
we're in the super tax base so if
someone is listening in they're in their
30s and they feel like they've done
every stupid thing because they have
your hope that they can turn that around
talk to that person right now maybe
that's the reason for our call we want
those listeners who are young who
sometimes get discouraged don't think
they can do it that they can they just
need to stick to it life will throw
curves at us all but stick to the baby
steps do it and and you can do it we can
do it you can do it like if I can just
say one brief thing I believe the law of
tithing coincides with the baby steps
and this is why the Lord says in Malachi
that he chastises the people for not
paying their tithes and offerings but
Benny comes back and says prove me now
herewith that if you live this law the
windows of heaven will open and
blessings will come down she's more than
you could handle I firmly believe and I
didn't know this until we got into baby
step seven that the baby steps are the
same way people who don't get on the
plan are robbing themselves of future
blessings financial peace blessings they
in half stick to it
keep adhering to the plant and when you
get the baby step seven you'll be like I
think where did this come from how did
how did this all happen and the
blessings just gone through immensely I
I can't say enough to just stick to it
and and keep going well way to go you
guys I'm very very proud of you it's an
honor to speak to you you're heroes I
love it
way to go your economic heroes that's
just good stuff man a million and a half
net worth love talking to you thank you
for calling in hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in
economy